[Music]
in a clumsy a criminal news like Joe
submitted by snack so snacks
oh yes maxilla smack smack so that's
never been it's just the slightest the
side but not this episode not the damn
oh oh yeah
a fling bank robber had the most epic
fail right in front of the police off
from front of a police officer
oh it would be so dope if he was running
and he thought that the doors were open
and he goes wound right into it glass
like what you did I know you ran into
glass yeah we jump up II we were like at
a YouTube convention or something
and then it's all these doors just
hoping this quick we're all following
him because I know we're taking out our
room just the two of us and I was
vlogging that yeah dude I rewind did
that like 50 times out I walked into the
door neva involving accidents are always
funny if no one gets hurt
yeah okay well I'm alone on that
sometimes you can give a [ __ ] you don't
think I heard a little bits funny
sometimes yeah I like natural disasters
so you asking the wrong person
you're like oh
I realize that food crust on it and then
I know that processor outside looked it
off romantic the intention of sharing
mystic looking like Java the goddamn
behind are you drunk
held up egg pink and then I still do
that yeah he held up a bank Bonnie and
Clyde in Maine this happening this is
Maine yet like thirty years nine he's
riding a train also no car I'm worried
about working at a small Bank in a small
town cuz I feel like those still get
held up Oh Stockton gets hold up all the
time well let's doctor yeah but a couple
banks get held up there like long time
yes oh this dude he held up a bank and
then so the bank employees called the
cops but then when this man was walking
outside near a parking lot he tripped
and he's cuz he slipped on ice and then
he ended up falling and all the money
and the gun came slipping out of his
pocket and he tripped right in front of
a police officer who just helped so
happens to be there and so they ended up
arresting him and people were like
trying to grab the money it flying
everywhere we don't know how much
exactly he stole but there were some
witnesses saying that like one person
picked up about four hundred dollars I
just booked it no like David I thought
they were taking off I was like they're
criminals too right in front of the cop
ya know if that cop wasn't fair though
probably huh
humans are pieces of [ __ ] sure bunny was
carrying was actually a BB gun at least
if someone dropped money and a gun I
would just watch but if all it's a cop
I'd be so stupid I'll be like oh let me
help you up here's your gun I'm a great
thank god you're not infants when I
forgot who it was the someone speeds
right past them they were like it was
like oh should we should we go get him
and then the cop was like no someone
going that fast has like had something
to do the word was but it was so much
yeah it's like the cops are yeah they're
just like my love what they were they
had to worry about anyway this is the
dude people who Hobbs focus too much on
the protect side not enough on the serve
side
packs me to my car there's my own back I
will be I will be the balance I'll be
the serve kind of cop like I'll help
people some criminals look like
criminals like they got nothing to lose
like that poor guy looks like he's got
nothing to lose like a lazy eye - I
think I know why he slipped you know
really focus he sees an blurred vision
yeah there is Jason
I think he's a transient that means
homeless that's a nicer way to say
homeless yeah I call him a [ __ ] bi
feel like transient is a worse word I
don't know why to me it sounds worse it
does like trans fats those are bad yeah
transit you fried food
yeah Gio Michael Esther yeah get
diarrhea okay
transient sounds like a municipal like
okay you do that's it it's like a bus
bus ride or some kind of like is it yeah
like a transit system or like
government-funded automobiles
doesn't I don't know it doesn't sound is
that a thing I just it just sounds like
a government thing traffic Metro
yeah like the bus service a train
service this is a really interesting
conversation oh yeah dude for real I'm
going back to your racism though I I
believe that you judge a book by its
cover
like people tell me like you have to you
know if someone looks [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] that person
get it fixed oh yeah so I'm punching the
[ __ ] out of my purse and it's to me it's
not it's not a racy thing it's not like
only black people
oh there's sketchy white people sketchy
black people [ __ ] sketchy people in
every [ __ ] race the only non-us the
only race that I haven't met a sketchy
person yet it's a sketchy Indian guy I
knew you were gonna say that
in America you know cuz the first thing
that popped in my head - if I was
thinking like I was going through my
thing okay not a lot of Indians like
that Cindy and I see all my trustworthy
upstanding citizen yeah you get maybe
like just all the ones I seen here yeah
this looks so friendly yeah yeah I mean
they just look like they want to live
and work yeah you know they don't look
like imma imma [ __ ] pickpocket you
like maybe in India that's probably real
about here it's just like let me just
offer you somewhere yeah like that's how
it looks like you know like I don't know
like I don't feel threatened I don't
feel like I'm gonna get conned I don't
feel like they're gonna pull a gun on me
watch you're gonna get conned people now
cuz you're gonna be like hey buddy bet
you anything it will be such a pleasant
experience like I'm gonna I'm gonna
welcome that like this robbery of a
witness you know what if I had to be
robbed by anybody I'm glad it was
Indians and you know who's the opposite
of that
that's like 99% sketchy except for one
or two friendly looking guys Armenians
where Armenians known is it uh New York
New Jersey New York - New Jersey - yeah
everyone says they're so grumpy it mean
I don't know I don't think I really
interactive I think it's just a call I
don't I just think other people don't
understand their culture we were me and
Joe and like Dave you stop play pick-up
basketball yeah there's this group of
Armenians that join our little pickup
game and they were yelling at I've never
seen the most aggressive basketball in
denim and dress shoes and they're
[ __ ] screaming at yelling at each
other and that's when I was like okay
it's not just towards other people that
is the cultures is very pretty much
Russian or like kind of I think they're
Russian
Eastern European but that's not I mean
like they're so close like their
neighbors oh yeah they don't smile ever
and they're really like I don't know
yeah maybe maybe it's just a culture
difference but I remember that game
because they weren't mean to us but they
were mean to each other
and I was like damn man yo yo aren't you
guys friends or enemies like what's
going on like we're just playing the
game man and they're just like holding
each other and I'm like oh you guys are
supposed to be the team man we're just
playing a basketball game maybe they
should have wore different shoes if we
don't play that serious but the
stereotype is all of them know how to
fight really good like they all know how
to do MMA that's the stereotype I've
never heard that yeah eat your ass whoop
anyway so back to Jason here the
transients who stole from a bank yeah
they're saying that he is bail was set
at $25,000 cash that he was arrested on
charges of robbery and terrorizing and
yeah he's pretty much held on probation
hold they say they they stole 400 or
someone saw him knows there was we
picked up $400 but we don't know exactly
how much no cuz it was like just all in
the wind I guess but if you're going for
a bank I'm thinking if I'm attacking a
bank which I know they're ready for a
robbery I'm gonna get like 10 mil out of
that if I'm just don't ever house that
much money ever you gotta hit the
Federal Reserve that's what I'm saying
I'm saying what you get the Brinks truck
I mean the goddamn bring sharp Hall I
believe Rick Ross has a Brinks trucks on
foot but I feel like it's only hundreds
of thousands maybe maybe maybe but my
point being is like if I'm just trying
to get a couple hundred bucks
I just know you grab somebody yeah
something easier than a bank I bet you
7-eleven has more look I'm not a burglar
I don't know what I'm talking about I
think I only keep like a hundred bucks
in the register though everything goes
into a safe that even the clerk can't
open the best place to Jack if you're
gonna Jack any hypothetically cuz you
know qui oh yeah could you what people
in a casino casinos are like it's a
restaurant
Oh cash-only restaurant specifically
restaurants that have alcohol yeah yeah
you know why they reckon a lot of money
or tips no they don't take the tips but
they they get so busy that at the end of
the night they have $50,000 in cash
thirty thousand fifty thousand dollars
in cash if they go out gone till like
4:00 a.m. that's a lot of cash man
that's a lot of your time thinking I was
thinking like let's say we need a
$50,000 even McDonald's there's two
shifts a lot of people that work at
McDonald's know this - like don't
collect don't collect money twice a day
right and by half of the day like that's
like 16,000 ish a lot of stuffs credit
card now - like a lot so electric like
you can't find cash and then what do you
do with you once you get that I watched
uh what's that show oh [ __ ] yeah I
learned a lot TIFF loves that [ __ ] it's
pretty good what do you do with what
like you can't just go buy you can't
just say like yeah I want a Lamborghini
of course and that's why money
laundering shady places money laundering
is such a big business funny like she
can't say the same things we do we don't
mean it that's why it's funny right mr.
white right so many people know what
I'll talk to you when you see I mean II
and you're saying that guy looks like
you robbed someone with that it's cuz
it's too much GTA and they look like
mobsters I guess like they have that
mobster look like oh you're related to
somebody and every time ice I've had
Armenian friends but every time I think
of our meaning I always think of big
family-oriented people but everyone has
a leather jacket at the or another
jacket yeah neither dress super [ __ ]
fly or very gaudy and loud that's the
median I think of the Kardashians cuz
that's all I really
oh they're Armenian they're white to me
yeah they're not I think I mean our
media and Kardashians to me they're
spicy white yeah cuz like you're not
saying bro after every sentence true
yeah